[Music]
the Iowa caucuses are just five days
away and it is still anybody's race out
there Bernie Sanders and Joe Biden are
the current frontrunner there according
to recent polls Amy Klobuchar Elizabeth
Warren and Peabody Josh are trailing
closely behind to find out what voters
want from the Democratic candidates pod
save America co-host John Favreau went
across the country looking for answers
holding a series of focus groups with
voters that Democrats need to win over
their highlighted in the second season
of the wilderness his other podcast and
Fabri who served as Barack Obama's head
speechwriter from 2005 to 2013 is here
at the table with us John good morning
I'm pretty good so we heard from Mitch
McConnell overnight into the evening
that he doesn't think he has the votes
currently to keep witnesses out of the
impeachment trial right but when you're
out there talking to voters does
impeachment even come up
it did not I was talking to folks in
late October when all of the Trump
administration officials were getting
deposed by the house where'd you go I
went to Arizona Wisconsin Florida and
Pennsylvania major swing states major
swing states yeah and the only thing
they could say about impeachment was I
hear a lot of people are testifying for
a long time yeah that's it and try and I
think President Trump did something bad
in Ukraine so they're not following
along now at the time they weren't so
it's divided as you put it's not really
blue red Democrat Republican it's like
paying attention not paying attention
it's it's the biggest divide in politics
and you know people will say that though
people who don't pay attention to
politics when Donald Trump is president
maybe they're apathetic maybe they're
ignorant that's not what I heard at all
people tell stories about health care
cost they told story about gun control
they want something done on climate
change their problem is when they turn
on their televisions they think that
politics is all about people who are
getting paid to yell at each other yeah
and and nothing's breaking through the
veil I was did you talk to Jon you talk
to Trump voters Obama though yeah so the
interesting group reporters I talked to
in Milwaukee were the Obama Trump voters
Obama voted for Obama then they voted
for Donald Trump and then they voted for
a Democratic candidate in Wisconsin in
2018 how do they explain that switch
they seem like very different candidates
yeah so I asked them and they said I
voted for Obama because he was changed
one guy actually said he wasn't an old
white guy so I voted for Obama and then
that guy voted white guy who said yeah
and then that guy voted for Trump and
then they voted for Tony Evers who's the
Governor of Wisconsin right now because
he was a change from Scott Walker
so it was change in Trump was change so
who's changed now well had Joe Biden if
by this perspective you know it's
interesting they they keep wanting
change because they feel that no one in
government has actually done anything to
tangibly improve their lives and so they
are in at least in Wisconsin those
voters are looking for someone who could
be different yeah but I was surprised a
lot of the voters you talked to really
only knew a couple of candidates right
they only knew Joe Biden and Bernie
Sanders a couple knew Elizabeth Warren
what does that say to you John it says
that most voters don't pay attention to
this process until the very end and
these are people who are going to vote
right like every single person said I'm
definitely gonna vote in 2020 most of
them did not like Trump that much in
fact most of the Obama Trump voters
actually we're very disappointed with
their but the the three frontrunners in
most polls are all white men yeah and
you've got women in four and five Warren
and Clovis Shar who have very similar
ideas to some of the people a little
higher in the polls what explains that
gender divide out there is sexism
playing a role still I think sexism
absolutely plays a role when I ask
people you know do you think it's harder
for a woman to become president or a gay
candidate or someone over 70 or a
Democratic Socialist I asked all those
questions you know personally everyone
said no I'm be fine with all that but
when I asked what about people you know
right then they said yeah I think people
would have trouble with you know a woman
running a Democratic Socialist so you
start hearing electability that way in a
new Quinnipiac poll Mike Bloomberg
cracked the top 5 for the first time
yeah about 8 percent nationally yeah
sort of that's what a couple billion
dollars okay yeah well I mean look at
Tom Styer he's not right same lucky he
spent quite a bit of money yeah what do
you think that says I think I think it
does have to do with all the money he's
spending I mean Tom Styer spent a lot of
money too but it's all pales in
comparison to Michael Bloomberg so I
think running that many ads and that
many places will get you a bounce the
question is like Mike Bloomberg if he
wants to be President it has to be a
real candidate you can't just run an
entire campaign on television I don't
think was there anything that surprised
you who went around the country
what surprised me was how passionate
people are about a whole bunch of issues
are not apathetic they're not as
pathetic and Indian everyone says health
care is on the mind of voters but you
hear these people tell stories about
avoiding an ambulance ride because they
were afraid of a couple thousand dollar
bill and it's not taking their
prescription drugs and all they want is
someone who would actually deliver on
the promise to fix that yeah but not too
much right they want change
not too fast I mean it's I've seen
people are not apathetic but they're not
passionate about candidates yet from
what Abroad's no they're not and what
they want is that you know Trump has
exhausted them yeah they wish they wish
there was someone who just wouldn't like
tweet and yell all the time yeah and so
they're looking for someone who can just
come things out heard they were out on
the trail to jon favreau thanks very
much